hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today
i am going to be reacting to some more
kevin samuels you guys seem to like the
last couple so i'm gonna keep reacting
to him
until i get more requests honestly so
before i start do not forget to like
comment and subscribe
especially subscribe as you guys know
i'm trying to move out of my parents
house
well not really i kind of like my
parents house but i should probably move
out at some point
so um so don't
do not forget to subscribe um yeah so
i'm gonna
i picked a random video and i'm gonna
start it
let's go to full screen
okay i think that a lot of women
do see because i personally understand
that i have a lot of work to do
personally
and one thing that i do love and
appreciate about you
is how you do stress and encourage
people in our community to get therapy
but one thing on the other end is just
feeling safe i did not watch your
video from last weekend but i heard you
talking about women
not smiling at men which i'm actually in
another country right now and
you know i'm from california i feel like
californians just smile a lot but in
certain
situations i specifically will not smile
at a man
because i do not want him to engage with
me because i don't feel
safe like i literally carry a pocket
knife on me
because i've been in situations where
men have come up to me
assuming that i was a prostitute men
have come up to me quartered me
in parking lots and i see your face
right now
but i mean i'm just speaking for my
personal experience
i am because i find it interesting i
just left california
and i'm watching women smile all around
beverly hills
but it seems that simply black women
seem to from what i hear is you attract
an inordinate amount of uh
rapist stalkers and men willing to do
you harm so
to protect yourself you walk around
strong-faced it with mace and a knife
i don't buy it
because i live in some of the most
dangerous cities in the world
when i feel comfortable when i'm out i
will smile at people
but if okay well then get what then
guess what
if it waits for you to feel comfortable
you will be strong-faced and alone
because the funny thing is the group of
women who are
feminine and smile don't tend to have
these problems
dang i've been agreeing with this man
more and more lately
i don't understand what's the big deal
like i smile all the time i've never had
an issue
and i lived in like downtown milwaukee
like i
i was down the street from like some
pretty dangerous areas
when i lived there i'm not going to
pretend i lived in like bad areas my
whole life but like i
haven't always been in the safest
neighborhoods
they tend to have friends around them
and support
y'all walk around isolated
uh-oh no i i mean
listen i don't understand these
statistics on that i mean i'm sure you
know
the statistics are from women
who have been sexually assaulted okay
man
we're going to talk about the mind i'm
not going to talk about the minority to
excuse bad behavior
it's bad behavior
simply that it's bad behavior and it's
funny that
when non-black you know what's a video
when non-black men ask black women to
smile
there's really not this kind of pushback
that's when black men ask black women to
smile we can make no requests of you
i personally don't there's nothing to do
with you dispers this as person
man we're talking about the group
ethnicity yeah okay i understand
when i'm at work when i'm in when i'm in
the halls of corporate america
and brad tells angela's smile she has no
problem flashing those pearlies
but when damian asked you to smile
but is this in a corporate setting or a
man
it's everywhere man
at what point are you ladies gonna start
recognizing the problem is you
black men have to go in look at what you
were doing i have to define
every scenario every setting for you to
pick apart my issue
walk around being unfriendly walk around
without no but here's the thing do you
want to be married
i do you want children yes do you want a
black man or do you care what racy is
i would prefer to have a black man how
old are you
i'm 26 why where do you think these
men are gonna how many children would
you like to have
between one and three the big number
which one one two or three
i mean three is preferred
and do you want to have to work to pay
significant bills after you're pregnant
with your first child
i mean i plan to continue to work do you
want to have to work to pay significant
bills after you're pregnant
whether you plan to work or not it's not
the point do you want to have to work
i don't have to work to pay significant
bills
see i think a lot of these women
are like obviously like would you want
to have to like
if you ask anyone do you would you
rather work or not work i think most
people would say
i'd rather not work but
like i think a lot of women are like
open to it if that's like
the hand they're dealt i mean i don't
let me ask you another way let me ask
you another way
what percentage of the total family
financial load do you want to have to be
responsible for for a lifetime
50 cent is sorry not 57 50
of the load is fine okay so that means
that mean listen listen listen before
you say that that means
if you don't work the family's at risk
you're paying 50 percent if i got two
i got four legs on a stool right but cut
off two
i'm at risk right you want to be
responsible for 50
for a lifetime to 65
that's that's that that's the math man
do you want to have
what percentage of the family financial
load do you want to have to be
responsible for for a lifetime
i mean it's what i'm willing to do it
depends
on what i said i want do you what you
want to have to be responsible for
see what you're willing to do is dif
that's why i asked it the way i did
but i feel that positions i hate it when
girls just don't answer the question
just answer the question like yes or no
no no no don't answer my question don't
don't tell them what you feel like don't
tell me what you feel like answer the
question the way i asked it don't
reframe it
of course i want my family to be
financially certain i answered the
question the way i reached
answer the question away and see what
see
answer the question out of 100 what
percentage of the
family financial load do you want to
have to be responsible for for a
lifetime
say 30 30
why is that so hard for you now if you
never get married right
if you've never married what percentage
of your fight
of your family what percentage of your
financial load would you have to be
responsible for
100 thank you see how quick that was
yeah but i feel that women should be
prepared to have savings to have assets
to ma'am you can feel like whatever you
want to but
you can feel like whatever you want to
but when you when a man comes to the
situation
women tend to think money just comes
from anywhere
so that 50 percent number was not true
you don't want to have to be responsible
for the mortgage the lights
the college fund you want your husband
to be responsible for the lion's share
of the bills
you may want to contribute but you don't
want to where if you stop
contributing for whatever reason you
don't want the family to be in jeopardy
true or false
true or false don't see i asked you a
question
and you are listening we're not what
what if they ever
i think the videos that go viral are
with the girls that are like the least
level-headed i swear or the most
stubborn i'm gonna go past it until we
get my answer if you stop contributing
you do you want your family to be
at risk or in jeopardy yes i do
no you don't no i do not thank you so
you'll need your husband to bring the
lion's share in that's more than 50
that's closer to 20
see 20 if you start working
we can still survive 30 you can't
survive with 30
take on 30 like the titanic you sink
and my ultimate point is this three kids
california is that where you say you
were i'm
i'm not very much california i'm from
california
i'm in mexico southern or northern
northern right how much money would a
man need to make to be able to fund a
family of
three children and two adults five
people in northern california
i mean
i have not done the math on that so i
don't want to just guess numbers because
i haven't done the math
just don't know about what you think
independently or with the wife bringing
in
minimum five man he's pretty he's having
to provide for eighty percent
how much would he need
250 000 i would say
no no ma'am in in dallas houston atlanta
that's three hundred thousand dollars a
year
350 actually northern california you're
talking close to about 400
thousand half a million
where are we going where are we going
with all this
man who's making the kind of money
you're talking to be able to pay for 80
of the bills or more do you think he's
going to want a woman who's not
friendly who's not smiling
those kind of men get women who are
extremely cooperative
feminine and friendly
but who's to say about women wasn't
walking with a man she wouldn't be
friendly or smiling because she feels
safe
you see how she just did that you've
seen that you see the [ __ ] lady like
you're not
you're not walking around in broad
daylight like
expecting i i don't know where she's
from
but like in broad daylight you can't
smile
and if you have like
someone that wants to do harm to you do
you think they're gonna be like oh
well she smiled i shouldn't you just did
some [ __ ] you put a woman walking
with a man
and everything else this is how far you
guys got to go to justify your bad
behavior
no i don't believe so i feel if a woman
feels safe when i feel safe i do not
mind i will smile
hockey works for healthy works for me
hopefully works for you when i was in
mexico
hopefully hopefully hopefully you can
find a man
a black man who is willing to put up
with you only smiling when you feel safe
because this goes deep for you because
it goes deep for black women but when
you're in mexico
did you smile or no in mexico or new
mexico which one
i'm in tulum mexico but what i was going
to say i was in the club
and i was smiling at women i was smiling
at people the main woman well
i was the only black woman in the club
no one was smiling back at me
so those women were not black actually
most of the women i
smiled at who didn't smile black back
were
white women
so maybe the experience is different
maybe white women love to smile at black
men
and not black women are you certain are
you
so i want you to be understood you're
talking about you talking about
black women smiling at black men you're
going to relate it to you and the club
smiling and women
i'm saying that maybe the experiences
that i'm just talking about
from what i've seen it's not specific to
black women
and you know what it is
i'm not going to speak on that i don't
know
i i have black female friends that are
perfectly from
mexico come on
and how long jesus this is the cognitive
dissonance
listen this i want we're talking just so
for those at home
i just gave all these breakdowns that
she gave me an example of her being at a
club in mexico one night
smiling at a group of women to judge
them
one it don't matter it's been the less
than a day a month
and we're going to juxtapose that
against a lifetime of lived experience
in northern california with black men
it's irrelevant
what with that it's irrelevant it's
irrelevant well we can we can stick to
the point
my point is women feeling safe first not
feeling safe so yes in the community
here's the thing when you don't smile
and he walks out with a white woman
you'll feel you can not feel safe by
your damn self
because this is what happens this is
what's happening
if if you only smile when you feel safe
that's up to you do what you do but what
i'm telling you
is the kind and calorie of black men you
want are tired of your poor
treatment that's it so while you guys
are deciding whether or not i feel safe
the barometer the temperature outside
who shot john
and every other group of women are
coming in competing
to be next to the kind and calorie man
you want and then they're competing
to see who can get his attention just
like the therapists who said
before no i don't think half of our
women are competing for the
average black men so if you're competing
for the average black man damn trying to
compete for the best of black men
okay don't say for not man
you do what you want to do but i will
tell you this is
the best behavior whether we realize it
or not i'm saying that
yes it is an issue yes i would love for
black people to just smile
freely at each other i mean that's a
hundred percent no no no black women not
black people it's not black people it's
not black women's black women it's black
people's black women
yes black black people black women i
want to see black women walking down the
street comfortable
smiling happy joyful night you know
you know how you fix that excuse me you
know how you fix that
he's gonna say fix yourself before you
fix the world how
with the person in the mirror yeah yes
and that's all you can do
the thing is ma'am you don't strike me
this is a long conversation about
justifying what
a black woman's not wanting to smile
because she does not
unless you feel safe if the barometric
conditions
if the conditions have to be right for
black women to just be as friendly
as most women are normally then you get
the outcomes you get
stop complaining about being one in four
of you will be married
stop complaining that the best of your
college-educated men go pick non-black
women stop complaining
because you're not even competing on the
bare minimum we're talking about smiling
being cordial just simply smiling
do you realize how ridiculous of a
conversation it sounds like to non-black
people
i have hundreds of emails about this
from non-black people emails and
comments like
jesus christ your women when you smile
at you jesus i mean
yeah this is a bit insane to me
you're not gonna just like i feel like
smiling is like the easiest thing you
can do
to just be nice but
and this is a real thing this is like
night two
and we get more women coming on instead
of just saying damn i don't know it's
just bad
wow how can we fix it it's well let me
tell you why we do it don't give a
french toast why you do it we don't like
it
we don't like it we don't want it if
you're not going to give the black men
what they want stop
asking for black men to give you
anything
about that that fair
i mean if you can't get what you want
black man shouldn't
get what he wants you both should just
leave each other alone right
i mean i don't think so but i mean there
are certain things
that we say women need to compromise on
and i'm not sure what about companies
black men are not compromising on human
[Music]
this is really interesting because i
have never heard of someone
like i'm sorry not being able to just
like
smile oh shoot what am i doing
i feel like that's like the bare minimum
so i i swear the more i listen to this
guy
the more i actually don't disagree with
him as much as i thought i
initially did but
you guys can let me know in the comments
is there something i missed something i
got right
something i got wrong i'm pretty
open-minded like
i could be wrong about stuff so let me
know in the comments also do not forget
to like
share comment subscribe
because you guys already know i'm trying
to move out of my parents house so i
will talk to you guys next time